uh
thank you for attending this talk my
name is daniel
i work at wolfram i do business here in
brazil
i'm computer engineer and i i have a
master's in
electrical engineering today i will talk
about
uh hot topic that is web apis
we're gonna see uh different ways to do
web apis calls
with wolfram technology this is a hot
topic
as i said we have a huge increase
of data in the next years and ahead
we're going to be talking about the
zetabytes of data
in the near future and then we have
information from online shoppers news
videos streaming
social media every kind of
images and photos and whatever kind of
structured instructor data you can
think about and then there are a lot of
value inside
this uh big data but the fact
is we should to find what we need
because in fact we don't need exactly
the big data itself
we don't need this amount of data we
need some data that is there
in the middle of this set of information
and we need to extract uh one part of
what we really need
and one good manner to do this to to
access this data is by
web apis most companies uh
they that have those huge amount of data
they uh provide apis
those uh web apis uh they are basically
texts
we can do uh http call
that is the internet protocol and get
responses
in json formats or or in xml
format doesn't matter uh what your
client
is your kite can be a mathematical
notebook
you can use a desktop application or a
web application
in any programming language and then you
can
send a request to the server that can be
anything like a php java javascript
whatever language and then they will
return a response a text
to requests and text as a response of
course they can send some binary data
too like
images for example but the fact is with
this communication by web api
we don't need to have that database
in the back end the database can be huge
like database from twitter or facebook
or amazon or whatever company wanted to
get information
and then uh we can just integrate our
application or data science process
with external information
i have an example here from
wikipedia data wikipedia data is a
function
from buffalo language that gets
information from of course wikipedia
and then uh what i did here i create a
list
with some acronyms related to the stock
and i would like to to have a a briefing
explanation about that
instead of writing this by myself i get
three lines of uh this information
from wikipedia text
and then i include this in my notebook
as cells and so i have this information
here
an explanation for each one of those
technologies and i didn't
write down this text i just get from
wikipedia
but then we can move forward and go deep
we can access
wikipedia directly of course
language provide you a way to to do it
in a easy manner in a more
elegant manner but of course we can go
and access
this uh directly and then for you to
have an idea
uh if you get just the english text from
wikipedia
and then write down in books you will be
more than 2000
volumes of books and then we can dig in
this data and
and do whatever we wanted uh to work
in this thing we should to go to the
website
from the company that provides the
the web service and check the
documentation
they will tell you the services the path
for that services and the parameters
they have
for example here uh this is the the path
to to make calls to wikipedia
that is there in their documentation and
then we have parameters
we send one parameter for example is
here format
okay here i asked them to send me
information back
in xml
i'm using just the simple function
import it's the same one we use to open
files in a local machine
we can get
html information or make api
calls with the same function it's very
easy
and so i do this here importing and then
we see here a piece of the the data from
wikipedia this is the
the main page this this parameter
here i'm asking the wikipedia to send me
the information from the main page uh
that they change daily basis
here i'm doing the same call but i'm
using another format i'm using json
those are the most common ways to get
information from
uh web api as a json or
as an xml file in fact it doesn't matter
um uh we can
process them both of them in woofer
language okay
and it's the same information we can
process uh
xml or json uh whatever they wanted
we have another way to do that that is
calling
uh using the service connect
this service to connect example i'm
calling twitter
i would like to see what happens
happening in the
twitter feeds and then um
when i run this uh this function here
uh it brings me this uh screen
i enter my credentials uh
on twitter so i should have an account
there on twitter
i i put my conditions the twitter will
provide a number
for you to choose as a key you paste
this key here
and then you're done you're done you
have a connection open it to twitter
very easily and then
i can now make a query for example i i
asked it for wolfer and so twitter
returned for me
uh the messages to the last 200
messages uh that have this text
wolfram in the in the
messaging the twitter messages okay what
i can do with this kind of information
for example i did a cleanup here i get
just the
text column that's the the message to
twitter message i transformed this is a
simple list
i get the text words and so i get
the the string the the text
i break it by space white space
and create a list and i get all the
this list together from all the 200
tweets
get it all together i did the lower case
and then uh delete stop rewards
and then here is a little inspection uh
in the data we have so we have numbers
we have words that have been used
in the messages we have
twitter users we have hashtags uh we
have emojis
and so on um and then to analyze this
data i
i'm using here counts that counts how
many times
each word occur in the list
and i i plot this thing here we
can notice that there is this rt
and this wolfram i need to take
them out because of course wolfram will
be here because
i'm looking for warframes so all the
messages they have the wolfram
word and this rt it means hate tweets
that when we request the messages the
twitter feed
uh we get the original messages and all
the retweets
that have been made and then um i
cleaned this thing up i delete this
information here
and more some garbage there i'm not
interested in
and see it again so we we have here
uh the most common stuff in the twitter
feeds when we talk about
wolfram we can use this thing to analyze
products clients
prospects universities courses people
famous people whatever you wanted you
can
have the fresh data from twitter
and see the trends what's going on in
the world every time that something is
happening like a disaster for example
you have lots of tweets
about that thing it's a very good source
of information for research
and for applications one
important thing here is that you can go
there to um
to twitter developer okay and can create
an account
to do a http call
but the issue is that those big guys
like twitter facebook and others
instagram and so on uh they are very
concerning about security
not just about the connection but about
uh
who is this person that need access and
ask
asking for access it's very bureaucratic
it's very uh hard to get access they
will send you a message but not just to
check your email they will try
to check what you want to do who you
are if you are a real person if you if
you are not going to create
a a crazy fake news robot do you know
and then uh using buffalo language is
very easy to connect to twitter
and other social media but when you try
directly by
http doing uh creating an account
it's a lot harder nowadays it's getting
really harder
and then to continue we're gonna see a
little bit
about uh how uh url works
this is something we use every single
day everybody every professional
have been using api where else every day
but
sometimes they don't pay attention what
it really means
the first thing here is it is the
protocol we have gtp and the tps
basically
but there are orders like ftp for
example
this is the domain the the subdomain the
super domain when you go to www
it's like we are going to a web page
many companies they use api here when
you're
gonna access information
programmatically
we have here the usually the company
name the domain name
and then uh the other top level domain
where we have
what is the institution organization a
company a
school or each country which stands for
from brazil from india from china
whatever here is the part usually if you
are using the standard port
you don't need to send this information
but
sometimes they provide services
many services in just one uh url
so you have different parts for
different services here we have the
resource
you wanted it can be a file or a text
file html file
or a program you can call a program in
the server
doesn't matter which language it is uh
and then you they when you do a request
an
application in the server side will run
and send a result for you usually a very
exclusive result
it's not something common it's something
that just you get in that moment
is something really different for each
user
we have a question mark here and then we
have
a key pair value we can have many of
them separated by a percent
and then we have a key and the value
separated by
by equal we can have many of them here
there is a there is a link here you can
the notebooks there and the
the event website you can download check
to learn more about those uh those
things i'm talking about here
uh well here i'm doing a call to
duckduckgo
dr go is a search engine this api is
nice because it do not requires any
authentication
uh you see here in the beginning api
instead of www so i will call this pro
programmatically not as a not as a
browser user this is the address
and here we have the question mark
and here the parameters
the first parameter here is the query
what i want to know
i'm looking for wolfram research i use
plus
instead of white spaces to escape the
white spaces in the url
and then this is the key value this is
the key and this is the value
i have enough percent here and later i
have the format
i'm telling them that i wanted the
result in json format
that is a javascript object
and then i have another one here that
i asked pretty equal one you you can see
all the parameters available there in
the documentation
you should go to the website that you
want to use the api
and they will tell you uh better how to
use it
sometimes the documentation is good
sometimes is bad
uh and here i have the the response from
the server
and then with import command again but i
tell report
that i will i'm asking for a json
message
you know and so it does those they don't
need to
infer what is the kind of data i'm
telling
in part that is a json
information i did the same thing here
but
now asking for xml and then
telling the report that i i'm getting
xml information
what i like to do okay as soon as i
i make a call for xml for for json5
is this thing here when you do a call
you're going to see that the call
is very fast it went there by the web
request and get back the responses very
fast
this information here is very messy
very messy the json they are a kind of
semi-structured data
we we can have nested data in this uh
data structure it's very useful it's
very good but
it's very messy to look and find out
what we have here i will just clean this
thing
what i do in the inside the wolfram
language is
i get the information i apply
association and
a data set and then i have a very human
readable
uh stuck to that view of the data
where i can see the fields what
informations i have in those fields and
i can dig because
uh the data set they support these
nested
data structures and so i can come here
in
mata for example and i can see what is
inside
i can get back in the structure
to the higher level and i can take a
look here at
related topics for example and i can dig
on the data it's really nice uh if
you're using
for example uh pandas from python
it just can deal with cartesian data
like uh spreadsheets like like lines and
columns they can do
they can work with those nested datas
another example here i'm sending the
the query again but here i'm sending
about sonia braga
i send the requests for documentary goal
and what i can do there when
transforming this thing here in
a data set i can easily navigate in this
data
and check what we have for example i
look for the abstract
explaining about sonia braga that's a
famous person so they have information
about her
and then i can get an image from her
this is the kind of stuff we can get
there's a lot of more stuff
we can get from uh ducky that goes
search engine
you can do connections for being for
google for other
uh search engines too
um here i have another example this is a
tool
that you is a combat light to you can
install in your computer mac windows or
linux it's very popular around
developers
web developers and api developers from
chain developers
they use this thing a lot it's a simple
tool
it's a simple command line you call this
thing and then
a service on the web and it just brings
for you
the json message or the xml message okay
what i'm doing here i have this program
in my computer
i'm running here this uh run process
this is nothing new
this is ram process it's there in
goofing language for a long time
and then i'm telling run process to call
this
program in the command line with this
parameter here
that is the the github website it's
going to get money from my user
information
and then i want to get back from one
process
they standard output and so i i'm going
to get
the i'm calling the application
the curl or c url as they say
and then they call this thing with the
parameters it goes to the web get
information
get it back and we turn this inside for
language
in text as a text simple text
i use this function here import string
to parse this text okay
and then i send it to a data set
and here it is i have all the
information that i bring from
a github api inside my data set
using an external application
combining it with external application
here i have another way to do that i
have a function called url
execute it's a more nice
way to work because i don't need to
concatenate
strings to compose the url like when i
use import
i should do that i should con conconnate
the strings and
with parameters and so on in order to um
to to have the appropriate call but here
i can
use just the base uh the base
url and here the parameters separated in
the list
and then it returns of text
as htp and then i use
import string again to parse this data
and then i send it to data set
and here we have the data from the queue
back go again
but now using url execute
there are lots of functions to deal with
http in the web
in mufon language there are there are
different styles different parameters
it's really cool
it's really rich there are many options
you should to look there
in the documentation it's really really
nice
the amount of options we we do have
uh one nice example here is the opening
street map
nominating nominating is to find the
the name of the street or the the one
address for example
at first look seems to be easy but it's
very hard it's very hard
because every seat has a main street or
a church street
or in brazil you every city has a
avenida brazil
everywhere you go we we have uh uh
different the same name in
different cities it's a very hard thing
to to work with
uh this is a very good api they provide
access
free access open access and then i'm
using part here again
here is the call for the api
where they are on the web and we have
the parameters here
one parameter that is nice is this query
here
i'm telling him that that i want to know
the
address of new york city central park
and then i make a call it returns a text
i run association and then
bring it in a data set when you look
here we have
very nice stuff we have the address
they say uh leisure suburb
county city stage country county code
uh we have here a level of importance
the type of location
uh we and we have the geolocation
the latitude and longitude of this place
and then
i can now as i have this information in
a data set
i can just get the latitude and
longitude and plot this thing
uh using our functions of gel processing
uh in ufra language
another example here i've got the same
data but i'm doing a zoom out
and look where it is inside uh
the new york city where is the central
park in
the new york city combining the maps
with the information we get from uh
from the nominating api here
i have another example for uh that is
white house where is the
the white house they give me here the
gel location again
and i plot it on geographics
and i can see combine the star
information with information
of creative data we have that's very
common
in warfarin language uh what more we
have here
um ah here i'm looking for a starbucks
in boston
it's the same idea i make the the call
the api call transformed is an
association data set
and then i can work with data set and do
whatever i wanted
and here is the location of the the
store
i have another way to go we knew
when you see the documentation of office
street map
they have another service where uh is
the opposite we can send the geolocation
and then they send for us the address
this is very useful
and so i have here the latitude and
longitude
i put this information here and the
formats they have many formats
you should just check in the
documentation the website
and then they bring me the address in
fact this is the ip address of wolfram
headquarters
in champaign illinois and it brings
exactly the address
all the correct address it's really cool
it's really really useful
and then of course we can view this
using
geographics here
another interesting api
is this one about news this new
newsapi.org they
they track news in many newspapers
around the world
in many different languages many
countries is really nice
and so they get together many
information from those sites
and give you a very easy api to access
this information
and then most uh of those
api providers you should go in their
website create an account validator
email
and then they will provide for you a
hash code that's called this thing
key and with this key you can go there
and get the data and they know who you
are how many calls
you do control the level of access or
sometimes they have a
a free level and if you really need lots
of information
they have pair paid levels where you can
can count and using our your application
uh here i'm using import again
but now i am using the key because if i
don't send a key
they require me to do an authentication
they don't give me the back the
information i'm
using json and i'm using this service
here that that called sources
sources they sent for me information
about
the newspapers where they are
connected where they get information
from and so that there is here
a bbc many different bbcs
there are um abc bbc
um associated press and so on there are
lots of
from what there are 128 in this call
here
uh in additional they have on services
that's called
top headlines this top headline is
really cool
uh we can't get what
what what are the hot topics and in the
news
and i ask here for example to
send me the information about the united
states
they get information just for for uh
newspapers from america and then
i get this i do this call send it to a
data set
and i have information here and then
i get just the the column title
that from the data that i received and i
did basically the same thing
break this down in words and delete the
stop rewards
and what's going on now in the presence
they talk about
trump they they talk about new new
effect i should to remove this word here
it's not a good word for this word cloud
uh but i i see york and times probably
information from new york times i said
news is another word i can delete
and they are talking about debates
series west days
and and a lot of stuff and here i do the
same thing with the description
but here i didn't use the delete stoppy
words okay
and so we have the end wheel office so
it's useless
this uh this uh word column
here is useless but with the same
information
deleted they stopped words i get here um
a lot of interesting stuff like they are
talking about president about
app event trump ratings debate
star pressure so we have a good idea
about what's going on
in the news uh well i think
our time is done uh
i have more examples here at this
notebook okay
you can download is available um at the
event website
and there is a a hint here uh
there's information about cryptocurrency
uh
financial market there's lots of apis
from the financial market you can get
information
there are information about images
here i get information from images and
then we can
use our artificial intelligence
super functions in order to check what
is happening what we have
this is one interesting where we can get
um
run the words look for a uh image
related to this render word in flickr
and then we use image identify in order
to check
uh our machine learning model
uh how it goes it's a very interesting
thing
it's very interesting um this is for
example
i asked for a protein i received a a
statue and with facial features we can
get the age
the sex and the emotion is basically is
basically right
for this for this statue it's really
nice we have cool
examples here you can check this out
and one important thing uh
we have uh is
this thing here there are apis for
everything
everything many different subjects there
are
streaming data like for stocks markets
there are
government information uh statistics
information it's really really nice
there is a link for a api
uh for a website in github
where developers update this list this
is huge there are lots of information
lots of apis
if you wanna if you need something don't
know where to look for
go ahead and take a look that you're
gonna be surprised
uh of the a lot of information you can
we can have there okay thank you very
much
for attending this talk stay safe
download this please this notebook for
you to see more
examples uh and feel free to keep in
touch
uh sandy mayo and if you if you have
questions we have
i don't know we we are
we are i have done in time but if you
have questions please
i'm available to talk i can continue
here at uh
at zoom if you want it
now there are some okay
okay no questions
okay if your questions rise up later
please keep in touch
daniella moser says do you know if
mathematica be used with the
google bigquery api um
no i don't know in fact i know i know
bigquery api but in fact
uh i guess you can connect by
a simple api call i never did that but i
i'm pretty sure
you we can i'm not sure if you we have a
function uh lingual for language that
does that
um uh ready to go
but i'm pretty sure that by apis you can
make
calls just check how to do that in the
the bigquery
uh in in
google api i have already seen people
accessing s3 for example that is
the files serv services from amazon
uh stephen showed in the keynote about
uh
we're gonna be able to send batch
process to
amazon but if you don't have a
a function ready to go
you can write this down and check the
documentation
any website that provides api it's very
easy
from the the wolfram side the wolfram
language site is really easy to connect
and
and access information thank you very
much and stay safe